(ska music)
- People sometimes here in
the US think ska bands died.
But it grew in other parts of the world.
And then it leaked back
into the Latin ska bands
that we have in L.A.
(fast ska music)
Most people in the rest
of the world don't expect
Latinos in L.A. to listen to ska music,
or even know about it,
but it's what we do.
(ska music ends)
(applause and cheers)
(latin music)
My name's Clemente Ruiz,
I'm a musician, producer.
I'm also the guy behind
the biggest ska punk
events we have in L.A.
I grew up running around in the streets of
Lynwood, Compton and South Gate.
I got shot at a few times,
I got mugged a few times.
If I didn't have music, and I
didn't have the ska punk shows
to go to, I don't know
where I would've been.
(uptempo music)
Latin ska punk has influences
from all over the place.
It's a genre that collects
bit and pieces of everything.
From Jamaican reggae, to hardcore,
to the Mexican, Latin ska.
It's just a clash of everything.
(latin ska music)
Latin ska started popping up
in L.A. in the mid-late 90s.
It was in the neighborhood.
We had a hard time
playing legitimate venues.
That's kind of what sparked
me having to organize
some of these events, because
no one would do it for us.
(slow dance music)
I think a lot of these
Latino kids in neighborhoods,
are attracted to ska music.
The way people dance,
the way people dress,
they just find themselves in that.
The rhythm really gets you going.
It touches a lot of people.
To a lot of these kids
that go to our shows,
it helps them find themselves.
It makes them feel like
they do belong to something,
it's a very personal connection to them.
(soft chime)